so i was born with an extra chromosome
i went to the doctor and i was feeling
tired and i was wondering like what's
going on
why do i feel like this maybe you're
depressed maybe you're overworked
of course i knew i was different but did
i know it was that definitely not hey my
name's sheamus
i'm 34 and i have 47 xxy
so 47xy basically means that i've got an
extra chromosome and my body
doesn't produce sperm and i have low
testosterone
most men with
47xxy have all these difficulties
learning difficulties being tired um
infertile
the biggest misconception is that extra
x chromosome relates to being feminine
and that's incorrect most people don't
get diagnosed until they're in their
like late 20s or early 30s when they're
trying to have a kid for example
so i knew i had physical differences
when i was 23 when i you know was
sexually active and meeting other people
and i knew i looked different
guys would say something you know and
they'd be like oh why is your
testes smaller or why are you sensitive
there
one of the symptoms for people and this
is what doctors find out eventually when
they do an examination is that we have
smaller testicles kind of like a grape
size that's why for example
a lot of us can't have kids
one of the big problems is like
erectile dysfunction
sometimes i'd just be like i don't feel
like it and
people would be like what i'd feel less
of a man if i couldn't for example get
it up and it happened for like three
years it was up and down up and down i
felt ashamed
embarrassed
my energy levels would be down i'd feel
fatigued i'd want to go to sleep and no
matter what i ate there was still
something else that i needed
february 2018 i was 31
when i saw the endocrinologist was in
there for 10 minutes saw the results and
then yep said to me you've got
47xy klinefelter syndrome that was a big
turning point obviously because it was a
it was a big i don't know i felt at that
time like someone had died it was a
really hard
hard time because it was like
now i can't have children
maybe i've got
osteoporosis when you say syndrome or
you were diagnosed like those words are
very strong you know and you feel like
what there's something wrong with me
like
that was very hard
thank god to my mum because she was like
trying to get me out of that hole that i
was in she comes from a medical
background so she just said look you can
go on testosterone you can
there's a chance that you can have kids
i rang around and then i found someone
that specialized in 47xxy
she was a lifesaver for me you know it
opened my eyes she said to me your brain
is starving it needs
testosterone and she spoke about all the
symptoms that i had like the learning
difficulties she answered those
questions for me and that was huge i was
like i just felt like i was dancing on
the moon at that point i remember coming
home and like crying with my mum you
know i was like oh my god
[Music]
it's treated with testosterone
injections
um which i currently have every 12 weeks
i really feel my life has changed i'm
more focused
i'm studying really hard
i'm training you know six times a week
and coming home feeling amazing and it's
taken me three years to you know get to
this part of my life like i fully accept
it now i actually embrace it
i think um i've got something special
and it's going to lead me throughout
life to help others and that's so
important for me so
guys get your crown jewels
looked at because honestly it could
change your life it's definitely changed
mine
if any part of my story today resonates
with you please click one of the links
below
[Music]